good evening stressful here welcome to
gaming week gaming we continue and so
just papers please
it's my son still alive probably not
dancer at Greyston Club founded this is
so sad
I am shaking and crying I probably had
something to do with the his November
19th glorious day inspector search scan
are very good yes collation must be a be
approved okay glory to arstotzka me
x-ray v8 your visiting friends
how long couple weeks color here stupid
color here I Spit on collection right oh
this is so crazy
you will not believe this you have been
selected random search it's never
happened before I swear no
discrimination dumb [ __ ] yinsen
what a stupid name what a stupid face
red door I've been with door it's
disgusting disgusting lady get out of my
sight okay
cool area whether horosho horosho
passport number okay a visit she say
visit right missing in the a-list dia
Alicia Alicia Stinson collector Stinson
passport Horror Show visit enter bye
okay okay okay does we done you next
cause no trouble check out new fountain
new found him very pretty
papers trust vote you transit how long
you stay couple wax transit horosho
okay first we check if passport is okay
okay what was I doing
okay this passport stupid passport
import what is this are you poor stupid
sookay doe horrorshow female nani
discuss okay what's your name Borla
greece ankle okay you were born in sook
in deco it was correct right
sook in deco and you expire what about
the serial number Hershel input enter by
I mean I don't see a problem they kind
of look different there on the picture
don't they let's check that oh it is why
you look old
I don't know what to say it's me
don't waste my time what do you have
here Borla applicant ring appraised
border like Gary's ankle so this is it
is correct she just had a really ugly
photo you look like a potato left in the
Sun for a century but you may enter a
show cause no trouble checkout fun then
check out new fountain what non matching
photo fingerprints do not make oh they
have to match the record I didn't know
that god dammit
they don't tell me the higher-ups don't
tell me and then they don't pay me when
I make problem why you bald
Danil super ok you need a lot of things
huh super Daniel male first we check
passport where is this oh bristan Aubry
Stan Passport
ok fine arts stupid job why you no work
for government
Danil super horror show and tell how
long one month
and this last one once okay and you
expire I mean I don't see problem but
there's always problem Oh
Aubry Stan okay where our show does with
Anya oh we forgot oh shoot
[ __ ] they're gonna fire me what did you
say work okay Oh God can I have your
passport back I need to check one thing
God please check out something
check out fountain eggs [ __ ] me
invalid now hey now I'm gonna get fired
check out fountain people please Ryan
but Ryan you do not look like man hey
what you look like old lady are you
women what is this question I this is no
discrimination what is this photo for
destro is it a district far Edisto you
are men
Wow are we were incredible maybe get new
haircut
okay you are 172 ok you are 7 to kill ok
you are born in date ok Oh same as me
very epic no way it's not all wake
Warner is correct everything is correct
sir again nor Ryan ok
check out fountain next I cannot get
another ticket otherwise my son will
literally die papers please
oh yeah ma disgusting 14 days I will
find something to kill I mean to send
you away that door I know the door
stupid city stupid people
good luck we have filthy Cola here ok
your say your name is justina you say
your name is crack but here it says
Krogh why it's a crow
why it's a scroll it says crag why does
it say matching that one is clearly not
matching that I did the video game
didn't oopsie matching am I crazy
oh it isn't I'm crazy I'm sorry it looks
very similar okay the number okay expiry
date is okay birthday fine you said
transit 14 days I want to get you
somehow fine hopefully I don't make
mistake oh my god I have to search her
come back come back and forgot
god dammit my son it's going to be so
disappointing
are you kidding me
this never happened this never ever
happened I can't believe I forgot to
search her ah you will select a random
search now I have to look at the ugly
lady instead of pretty lady damn I hate
my job I mean I love my job glorious
Totsuka disgusting filthy collegia what
is your work permit Fabia severity Fabia
severity your Co City worst place I've
ever been
I got chlamydia in your code it's not
good woman not good I mean I don't see a
problem but there's always a problem
next check out fountain
next no problem
that's be dunya basic this is crazy
this is not happening and it's first
time I work here but it's saying random
search incredible
stupid shadow it Safari Safari shabby
what stupid name what stupid pet what
does this what is this no weapons or
contraband why you carry this there's
zero tolerance you can see that slow
down my friend
I have only harmless medicine I give you
ten credits to let me through you cannot
bribe an officer a virus Totsuka they
pay me they must pay you well for such
opinions they don't pay me at all
next entry not guaranteed oh my god what
happened to you lady you're visiting
friends how long three months okay now
we check passport you are from untagged
area is that correct yes da Sant Moreno
a cent murmur no it's very nice in
summer what is your password is correct
and you are born very old lady wow
you're very old you're so awful how are
you so old
why are you so old Karina lab no lab
knows the visit enter by okay not enter
by this expire old lady go back to old
lady country I don't care you busy
reject denied by bike
you will not enjoy fountain you will not
enjoy the family entry not guaranteed my
god you're ugly
your Integra Glorian Cara Shaw every
young gross gay dross okay Everly oh my
god you are ugly lady emigrate forever
in our glorious City why why we do this
oh look at this dude check it again
detain detain send it off to gulag you
will not enjoy the fountain entry not
guaranteed oh what a glorious day my son
is sick okay
today my son today I'm very happy today
my son will get the medicine wait I can
upgrade both I will upgrade proof
instead I can't do a anything anyways Oh
[Music]
iris Tosca has zero tolerance for
delinquency what is this your family
will be sent back to the village you are
under arrest until your devs are repaid
no no glory to arstotzka yeah oh yeah
hey I have failed are you kidding me
okay we are back glorious day nothing
happened
okay new rules the collection have filed
complaint open stupid collector a
diplomat will arrive today for
high-level discussion automatic searches
of collection citizens no longer
authorized yet
filthy crybabies diplomats require only
a passport and very diplomatic
authorization refer to rulebook Perazzo
next dobri we hear papers kaalia
diplomatic our well where is your
diplomatic of the rice oh you have it
okay fine let's rub ski stupid name
herself stupid name your code city worse
city my cat got aids in your code city
ah you're good sucks
okay what is your passport number nine
to be LW 3 9 4 6 H and you expire by
fine your Co how long you stay in our
city how long you want to be in here
fine check out fountain next next the
papers I don't have all day
I have to upgrade booth my presence was
ok what is this diplomatic
authorizations diplomats are you
diplomats oh sure ok
you're from obsidian ok it's not erased
obscure but it's not bad my god you look
ugly on photo is this correct
while you look so ugly mahir years have
been cruel
let's check fingerprints give me this
name de Jean Negreanu gromova is this
correct okay it's correct you give this
back do I give this back
Maya my dog is barking it's very
stressful do this job okay number that
Jeana gromova diplomatic authorization
fine I don't understand I don't
understand what other diplomats require
authorization da but you are not from
impulse oh it means you can enter these
places ah I understand of course of
course of course very well you can enter
that's we Daniel yet non matching photo
finger prints do not match record what
are you talking about oh my god is this
guy are you happy to see I have
everything you asked for now oh wow it
looks so real what is this hey can I ask
matching day oh wait has it expired what
do I get him for
he needs a entry permit we don't take
ticket hey no guys help me take it say
it's good you check again maybe I'm
sorry you need every ticket come back
again
ha ha you nice guy but I have business
in our thoughts can I get write papers
and come see you ok very well next
papers place with this purpose you plan
to work ok one year you enter by 1212
horrorshow
Mika arrange Mika arrange you look very
ugly what what is this you tell me
listen I do not discriminate but why you
look like one man why do you ask for no
reason
random search Oh
collect yeah I almost didn't search you
but why what I Spit on collection why
you wearing man clothes there is a
problem with your documentation detains
gulag next you will not enjoy fountain
yes glory to arstotzka what money order
awaits
what no need this car oh it's big legs a
glorious day to you
kaliesha why you come here
this is crazy wait she needs a little
man right I'm no longer allowed to
search them damn it
Oh west Crescent terrible place I lost
my left testicle in West Crest okay you
want to immigrate ah why you came to
live with my husband stupid their van
Josephine
their van Josephine CP all West Creston
West Western Horror Show passport is
okay to me and number you look very old
forever enter by 1122 I don't see
problem but I also don't want to accept
you
is there anything what would it be just
VIN better one why this expired I could
not come until now but that is not my
problem
will the collection go back home right
you will not enjoy fountain papers ah
thought sky welcomes you back octave
Alice district this is very good
district my father became immortal in
this district octo Valley is very nice
it's very nice area
I'm told you are 162 this is standard
procedure I am so sorry for taking time
your precious time glorious arstotzka
Lee always very similar more acts
obscure more rock
Hacha issued in parodies 'no oh you got
from different district that's okay
apparently 1982 11 13 11 13
oh no oh no oh no your document is
expired it's a mistake I just renew it
okay Cara show there is no fountain so
come back soon okay next entry not
guaranteed next papers what is this
visiting friends are how long is they 90
days that is correct
pewter malenko pewter malenko it's been
three months
Santa Maria mo it's actually not bad
aunt agrea santomero you look a little
tired Esther a problem visit three
months he say visit but why this is work
permit or is entry permit am I crazy
basic rules workers must have worked
past I am crazy
oh he is not working that's why it was
it looked like the word pass I'm stupid
okay I think he's fine fine go then I
don't care
enjoy look at fountain enjoy fountain
come on
yes enjoy fountain papers Oh iris Tuscan
welcome back home Drake's Carmen I hope
you had good stay you don't have to be
in dirty City anymore
your mail car oh sure
I grew my first nipple in parodies nah
it's very good players parodies no more
like parodies nuts am i right
okay sorry not funny I make joke pass
time quicker you know my son is sick not
your plug problem of course what am i
doing I'm just making sure everything is
okay
what is I'll be reset Vasily low I think
he's okay
you okay dad have you seen new fountain
if not you should look my son is very
sick
your son will die without medicine this
is so sad another glorious day okay
let's do one more top level collector
and expose that iris not conspire what
not me this is crazy
December 1st glorious day what is this a
pig
inspector an undercover agent of the
Ministry of an information has been
compromised
what expect a possible drop of letter
next yeah what who are you
hello are you the spy
what no never
I am guard here my name is Collins they
told me I get good position then send me
here this is thanks I get now they pay
me almost nothing they pay us all as
much don't complain
yes but look I get small bonus when you
detain people more detain more they give
me for processing but this is not fair
you should get something too so I fix
problem I give you 5 credits for every
two people you take sounds good deal I
give money to you after I get paid
like let us make best of this okay it's
the same time next okay who are you Oh
what is purpose pass-through duration
two days okay so your name you say is
Thomas carpenter carpenter you from East
Creston it's not bad place it's not good
place there is no East grayskin an
import what is this the issuance it is
not correct I don't know anything about
that
b-day get out send him to gulag you will
not enjoy fountain you will never enjoy
a fountain again if people don't
appreciate the good panting okay you are
transit what is your name two days this
is correct
what are you from república excuse me
let me check a república laser indeed
ask that is correct and the passport
looks correct to my fellow friends is
very cute okay cause pass vegas-y your
name has began in it why why this is
your name don't understand ok horosho
trend enter by 1213 that is correct car
show okay
thus we done yeah look at no fountain
papers plays I have not much time you
must hold on to these what is this
keep them safe today I am being followed
by ambassador they pretend to be from
ministry information but it is lie if
they ask for documents give them these
instead do not get too mixed up gosh oh
so wait which one I give this one okay
Farah show me ax papers please I am NOT
your delivery service do not leave me
documents visiting friends how long you
stay couple months marry gatherers what
is this place never heard of merge areas
this is real are you lying to me
you better not lie I have eagle eyes
there it never be I never make mistake
law Mary Gary is real it's crazy
never visit Harmon Sebastian what stupid
name add man what is your passport Dean
okay okay it's correct enter by twelve
nineteen is correct your mail your mare
garius you are really old and really
ugly and I don't like your face this
expires by the time can you do that well
you should get new passport you dummy I
think it's fine check out fountain yes
come on I don't have time next what's
purpose visiting how long okay
Penobscot Emily Emily van nose cap you
are very very not pretty
help me okay the number is correct and
this expires when next year that is
correct
Lorna's is that inab straighten I forgot
oops trillion you dummy
Lord mass this stupid place I don't like
it enter by 12 27 this is all correct
enjoy a new fountain yes I want to
detain people I need money papers come
on
papers papers I am from the ministry and
information you have something to give
us are you giving me money
all right so I'm supposed to give you
this but I give you I don't know I guess
I give this yes you know I guess I can't
give them both I have money
I eat tonight I upgrade booth for this
purpose visiting friends all right
where's your stupid passport where your
passport give it to me
dumb snake sorry you don't have it oh
you have it okay fine so she say she
visit for a few weeks one month and you
have to enter by today you know you're
fine and this expires is fine you rate
ok passport number is it correct the
female the skull from skull is actually
not that bad place
they have sea fish in skull because they
made of skull the donor the donor Ian
look
girl look horosho you look you look a
little crazy I got to say it is correct
she busy it's all correct but I need to
detain fine enjoy fountain yes come on
oh my god there I need to detain someone
Oh
my fellow artist Otakon welcome back how
was your trip terrible I'm sure it's
awful out there
Durex Carmen now dregs I am so sorry
are you do look like female action never
mind you're from East cresting is
getting the greatest place in our
structure we have fountain in Heath I'm
sure you've seen many times this
fountain and this was issued in Alton ah
that is correct
everything looks great you are 40 near
okay when this expires enjoy the family
wait my name is Carmen GRU you have
something of mine please no I don't what
is this read quickly aerosol skies great
country poisoned by corrupt leaders
which has made the help free arrest
Otsuka the order of Erick okay I read do
not lose this what is this what is this
oh it's my time day nine your son has
died I am absolutely devastated my son
is dead
it's in the chat okay boys that was end
of episode hope you enjoy goodbye what
you never play too / simulator you know
it's fun right I'm not supposed to give
my opinion but give it a try and then
you can tell me if it's good or not
convinced yet okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]